moi j'aimerais que laborantine c'est un
métier qui me plaît c'est un travail ou
qu'on ne travaille pas dans les bureaux
parce que j'aime pas les bureaux je
voudrais rentrer dans la marine
nationale
parce que la mère me plec
faudra peut être encore terre ça
m'intéresse puis je pense qu'ils
voyagent beaucoup alors j'aime bien les
voyages moi j'ai pas une idée fixe
il ya des métiers qui me plaisent mais
j'arrive pas très mon métier je voudrais
faire mécanicien radio volant parce que
c'est un métier qui mme pla et j'aime
bien les voyages et sa présente certains
avantages pour quand on veut aller en
voyage quoi tard à lyon j'ai parlé du
fait que certains métiers pas d'idées
pour quoi faire
je vous arrête ce regard 10 parce que
j'aime bien et téléphone et j'aime pas
au dans un bureau c'est calme ça a voulu
être avocat parce que c'est un métier
qui est qui gagnent beaucoup plus tard
quand arrêter quand ce sera s'est
qualifié à me mettre à mon compte pour
faire de la politique
moi je ne peux vraiment pas ce que je
pourrais faire
je sais que dans les bureaux ça
m'intéresse pas je sais pas
le pas dès que j'aurai de cuisinier
parce que la cuisine ça me plaît comme
ça on est sûr de manger à sa faim
puis c'est un métier qui fera jamais
faillite je voudrais que tu offert
livreur parce que c'est un métier qui me
plaît beaucoup j'aime bien la conduite
d'un camion et on voyage beaucoup
[Musique]
c'est un jour je vais te travail et
amour avec mon père et ça ça m'a plu
alors c'est le métier que je voudrais
faire plus tard
[Musique]